Timo ehdottaa, että kansan edustajille ja hallitukselle säädetään tulospalkkaus, lähtöpalkka noan 2000, ja sitten kun valtio ja kansalaisten talous ja hyvinvointi lisääntyy,
pois eduskunnasta, jotka eivät saa mitään muuta kuin pahaa aikaisiksi, ja tyhjentäävät ansiokkaasti valtion kassaa, vetämällä tyhjänpäityn kovaa palkkaa, siis tuhouspalkkaus edustajille ja hallitukseen.
Se on ehkä vaikea mitata, mutta kyllä sen näkee ja kokee kansalaiset. Tämä olisi hyvä systeemi. Kiitos, hei.
Kansalaisetusta ja kommenttia, niitä on lisää luvassa, tämän juuri alkaneen jakson aikana ei pääty tuohon ensimmäiseen puheluun.
Se on kansanradio, ja Lasso Olki nuora tässä, tervehdys.
Kansanedustuslaitos ei tietenkään ole ainoa aihe tällä viikolla paljon, ja hyvin erilaisista aiheista on tänne meille taas soiteltu.
Siis, sivareista muumimukeihin ja villisijoista yleisurheiluun.
Toissa viikonloppuna Tuusulassa poliisi kiilasi mopoilijan ojaan, se uutinen ja se video sai suomalaiset kyllä keskustelemaan aika kovaankin ääneen ja ärhäkästi.
Tänne kansanradioon siitä tuli heti välittömästi todella vähän puheluita, vasta nyt tässä menneen viikon aikana ihmiset ovat soitelleet aiheesta.
Mutta niinhän meitä ihmisiä nykyään kehotetaan, että joku aihe kun nostaa oikein tunteet pintaan, niin anna pulssin vähän tasaantua, ja sitten vasta lähtee kommentoimaan aihetta.
Nyt on käyty tästä mopo-meetingjutusta aika paljon juttua, ja väärinähän sinne meni, ja lapsia ei saisi tollaan kohdella.
Mutta on jäänyt kertomatta poliisilta, paljonko niitä miitinköjä on, paljonko siellä rikotaan sääntöjä, määräyksiä, ja paljonko siellä laetetaan väärillä rikollisilla moottoripyörillä, siis toisin sanoen, virteltyjä, ynnä muuta, ynnä muuta.
Vois poliisit kertoa, sit ku tää rauhoittuu, tää tilanne, miks ne käsitelee näitä, niitä nimittäin niitä haistatellaan tuolla jutuissa, ja näytetään keskisormia, ja taidetaan vähän sylkeekkiä, ja ainakin kiroillaan.
Vois nyt tehdä niinku tämmösen paljastuksen, jos vois sanoa. Vitos moi.
On taillut Suomen poliisi kattoo vähän liikaa sitä brittilästä UK:n poliisien arjahti-sarjaa. Mun mielestä jo onakin pitäs vetää se raja, jotta ei tuo vaan niinku lisää nyt to homma, koska ne on verorahoilla, kansan palavelijoita, nämä poliisit, eikä mitään ylimistöä, jotta tätä mieltä minä oon. Kiitos.
Tätä vaan, taata poliisi ei ole niin purmunen, kuin sitä luulisi. Kiitos.Näkemiä, ei vaan kuule.
Jussi, tässä, hei. Siitä Tuusulan tapauksesta, mopoiluesta ja mopo-meetingin liittyen, niin miksei niitä voida tehdä ihan laillisesti?
Näkseen tieosuuden käyttöön, tienön omistajalta ja haltijalta, kolko, kunta, valtio tai muu. Tekee ilmoituksen viraomaisille, nimismiehelle tai poliisi puolelle yensä.
Sit tekee siihen paloja, pelastussuunnitelma, et miten siinä toimittaa. Ottaisin ne järjestyksen valvoja, mitä ne viraomaiset määrää, kakskymät vai kolmekymät henkeä, ja sitten tieturva ykkönen, tieturva kakkose, omaava kortit kavereille, ja sitten ensiapu ykköstä, ensiapu kakkosta.
Jaha, helppoa hommaa.Sit palkkaa, sitten jonku pelastuslaitokse, sinne ensiapuja pelastustehtävii, noita vapaaehtoisia VPK-laisia löytyy ympäri Suomea, ettei oo mikään ongelma.
Sit tekee siitä ympäristölupa, paperi, ette, kuinka vaan aulua suljettua, mimmonen meteli tulee, siihen löytyy ihan paperia.
Sitte ottaa vakuutuksen järjestäjille, ja ottaa vakuutuksen jokaiselle ajajalle, ne oo henkilökohtaisi.
Pyöröt ja kulkuneuvot on vakuutettava, niis pitää olla liikenevakuutus, ettei se häiritse.
Jos karkaa käsistä, ni löytyy OK.Tällö ei vaadita kuljettaja kohoa, laitteeseen korttia, ja...Tällö poliisi ei puutu asiaa, se voi käydä siellä ulkopuolella, mutta sillä ei oo mitään tähän muuta.
Muuta, ettei järjestätte, ja kaikki menee ihan hyliet.
Opetetaan nuohda tämä lakia asetuksi, ei keulita tuol tiellä, niinkuin palioile, ja lähdetä karkuu, vaan pysästetää ihan laillisesti.
Ei se kaveri oo, siin oo nii huono näkönä, ettei huomaa pelise auto.
Tai sit ei tarvi olla ajoneuvon haltijana ollekkaa ajaiset.
Ei muuta, ei.
Viikon alussa, kun avaa kansanradion vastaajan, niin nopeasti käy selväksi, että kyllä löytyy tästä maasta iso määrä asioita, joita ihmiset haluaisivat viilata vähän parempaan kuntoon, tai tuumpata.
Meil on tullut viestinimimerkillä huolehditaan terveydestämme.
Kulkiessani keräilen roskia, ja varsinkin myymälöiden parkkipaikalta, kun menen ostoksille.
Roskikset ovat lähellä, mutta niitä ei kaikki käytä.
Sieltä löytyy jos jonkinlaista poimittavaa.
Tyhjiä tubakka-askeja erityisesti, ja nyt tuli vastaan ihan täysikin tubakka-aski.
Empää ole aikaisemmin kiinnittänyt huomiota tekstiin, ja kyllä löytyy varoituksia.
Niin kysymys kuuluu, että eikö ihmiset piittaa edes omasta terveydestään.
Kun siinä lukee, että tupakointi vahingoittaa hampaita ja ikeniä, tupakansavussa valtava määrä erilaisia myrkkyjä, siis todellakin tappaa ja vie terveyden.
Terveys on paras omaisuutemme, terveyteen kannattaa sijoittaa.
Näin siis nimimerkki huolehditaan terveydestämme.
Vanhus soittelee sinne päin, hyvää ehtopäivää.
Hyvää ehtopäivää, sanotko kateelinen?
Niii.
No, minkä takia kateelinen?
No, ku tonne kaupungine menee, katrualeen menee, taika minkä päivä ne menee.
Siel ku silmä pitää levätä, niin naisilla ku rintaliivit ja bikinit.
Naisilla ei oo päällä ku rintaliivit ja bikinit.
Niii, no tää vestivaali ku kattelee TV:stäkin, niin siellä oo valtavasti tulee,
ja vähä pukeesia niähän pääsee, siel oo halavalla vaatte penustossa.
Aa, he säästävät, ku ei tarvitse nii paljon laittaa kankaaseen rahaa.
Pitäisikö meidänkin sitten ottaa mallia tästä, tästä festarimuodista? Säästetää mekin rahaa?
Ei, mä en oo yksinäkään, yksinäkään vestarisee järjest käynykään,
ja tässä aikaa konistelemaan toi pitkä kilometymä, eli oo meikä rasika.
Ei toi, voi niitä vanha liiton miehiä.
Nii, nii just.
Toinen, mikä osainen, mitä mä oon huominoi ja mistä vaan oi pitkään aikaa,
vähän liku myrkistyny nänä, että ku nii.
Tua näkee tyttöjä, jolla on säädepaljaana, mutta niinko nois kävel jostaa likamoituun pohrasta,
ku kädet, jalat on, säädät, käsivarveet ja säädät on,
on kaukaa kattoo, niinko nois likaset. Ku ne oo niitä tatuointeja.
Aaa, okei, jo, jo, jo.
Nee, moi, moi, siis tää on vaan minun mielipiteeni,
se ei tee nais kuin kätikse millään lailla.
Nii.
Tatuointipuoli on, joka puolel on, ne kyllä aikut,
käsivarveksi ihan olkapäntämöitä.
Nee on nii maku asioita, noi jutut, ku mä muistan juuri,
juttelin yhden henkilön kanssa, joka oikein niinku ihailemalla ihailee toisten,
niimisten hänellä itsellä oo tatuointeja, mutta tykkää nimenomaan katsella, ku muilla on.
Tatuointeja, joo, ja en ne vaan, no, kun minäkin on maailmaa huoludu kiertää,
niin sen, he, mies, joka tuli vastaan, ja se oli käsivarveksi tatuotoniseksi,
ja se oli varmaan tarkkaa, että se on ollut linnassa.
Nii, just, merimies tai linnakundi.
Näin on, se en ne vaan, navelettiin, vain linnassa letä.
Kust, ei, mitää tuota, tää, tää on mua tosiaan, niinko, hän on jo kiusannu.
Nii.
Pitkän aikaa, ma, tää on oman kannen, tää on siis minun oma kantari.
Nii, ihmisellä on oikeus oman kantaa, kyllä.
Hyvä, hei, mitää, ku et tuota, ni, hyvää, päivää, eivää, jatkoa sinne, Paku.
Minä toivotan ihan samaa, kiitos.
Hyvä, kiitoks, ja ku olemens.
Kiitos, moi.
Muominmukki fanisoittaa.
Muominmukki on liian pieni.
Se pitäis olla semmonen korkeampi ja isompi, koska siitä on parempi juoda, ja pitää katsoa, että kahva on kunnolla.
Harotsin muki, jonka mä oon saanu, niin kaks kappaletta.
Se on tarpeeksi iso, ja siinä on kahva, eli siitä, mistä pidetään kiini, hyvässä asennossa.
Ne on mainioita mukeja, ja semmoista mä oon Suomessa hakenu, mutta muumi tekee liian pieniä.
Nyt täytyy lonserrata suurempi muumimuki, missä on kunnon kahva. Kiitos.
Olen 80-vuotias nainen, ja haluaisin, että ostettavien sukkien, nilkkasukkien ja polvipituisten sukkien kantapäät olisi vahvistettu.
On ikävä, kun ne menevät puuhki kantapäästä, parhaillaankin minun kantapääni ovat paljaana, vaikka muu sukkapolvi tai peseen asti on aivan ehjä.
Paljon sukkia hukkaan, voi kääntää tietysti kotioloissa sen reijän tähän nilkan etupuolelle, mutta ei niillä semmoisilla sukilla sitten voi oikeaan mihinkään tilaisuuteen mennä.
Varmaan on olemassa hyviä, vahvoja sukkia, mutta valtaosa kaupassa myytävistä on mösiä.
Tähän asiaan minä toivoisin parannusta, en ole ylipainoinen, että ne sen tahden menisivät trikki niin nopeasti, kun ne menevät.
Kiitoksia, kuulemi.
Joo, mä perätellä uudeltamaan.
Masta perä huomenta suomea kattelee, että ykköselle tulee selkosoimeksesta uutiset, mutta se pitäis, MTV kolme toimittaja, mikä tää on, se vaan puhuu okei, okei.
Eikään pitäis jonkinlainen kirje, kielä on ollut toimi, toimittajalla.
Mutta semmoista on vähän kiinnittää huomio, kun se tulee aika usein.
Täällä samalla toimittaja, okei, okei, mutta se siitä, okei, ei muuta.
Vein osoittelu tästä siviilipalavelusta, kun oon kuunnellu ja epäilu, että onkohan tuo Ukraanan porukat, ni porukastanne paljon siviilipalaveluukkoja ta akkoja, kun ne pärjevää ni hyvästi.
Kuitenni tuota isoa rohmu Venäjä vastaa.
Ja suomalaiset Suomessa ei osais ollut siviilipalaveluja, joita silloin talavisovassa ja jatkosovassa, ni eipä taitais olla koko Suomea olemassa, ta.
Minä en arvosta näitä siviilipalaveluja millä tavalla.
Tä siinä siviilipalaveluja häviää hyvin äkkiä, kun Venälä ne hyökkää Suomea.
Tää on minun mielpie, ja varma mielpie onni.
Eepä rallau.
No nii, nimimerkki tyytymätön.
Ihmettelen tämmöstä asiaa, ja kuka on keksinyt sanonaan, että Suomi on maailma onnelisin kansa.
Eihän se pidä mitenkään paikkaansa.
Kysykääpä vaikka työttömiltä, pienituloisilta ja eläkeläisiltä.
Taloudellisestihan heillä kaikilla menee todella, todella huonosti, ette.
Ei heidän mielestä Suomi on maailman onnelisin kansa.
Kysymys onkin näistä kelan maksamista, tuista, joita aina vaan leikataan ja leikataan.
Eihän ihmisillä jää enää rahaa esimerkiksi lääkkeisiä.
Et tietenkin, mitkä on suurituloisiani, heidän mielestä on onnelisin kansa.
Ei muuta kuin kesänjatkoja.
Heippa hei.
Hajamielinen ihminen minä olen, mutta aika varma minä silti olen siitä,
kohdistettua viestiä, sellaista on vielä lisää luvassa.
Ja näin on. Seuraavaksi kuunnellaan niitä.
Kyllä nyt kaikki työttömät äänestää kankikaikkosen seuraavaksi pääministeriksi,
ku se esitti, että työttömyysturvasta ja sosialiturvasta pitää tehdä pastikkeelista,
elikkä sillä lailla, että kaikkien kepulaisten ja kokoumuslaisten isojen maatilojen pelloille
mennään saron korjuuseen, sirpilä, viljat leikataan, heinät niitetää viikatteella,
perunat kuokitaan, kuokalla ylös maasta, ja kaikki leikkuu poimurit ja isot miljoona raktorit
pannaan romutukseen, niistä maksetaan romutuspalattionille maatiloille,
kun ne on ostanu kallita neliveto raktoria ja leikkuu poimuria,
ne romutetaan, kaikki tai lahjatetaan Venäjälle, sitten käsin, kaikki sato korjataan käsin,
ja kaikki työttömät orjiksi maatiloille, ei pakseta palakkaa,
jos ei viitti nostaa omia perunoitaan, mitä syöjä, marjojaja, kaikkia, porkkanoita ja pianneksia,
kaikki pannaan orjatöihin työttömät ruoskimaan, ruoskitaan vielä sitten,
kaikki pääministerit ja ulkoministerit, nämä herrat pannaan ruoskimaan työttömät, kiitos.
Sasoittele tervee, sellainen hallitukselle hyvä säästökohde, ni kansaitusten taa sopeutusraha, ni laitettais puolen vuoden pituiseks maksimissa,
ja maksamiseen ehdoks neljä työpaikkaa hakua kuukaudessa, tällainen säästötinkki. Kiitti.
Muori hämiestä, hyvää päivää.
Mielestäni ton hallituksen olis tarttis kokeilla vähentää, ensisijaisesti, että leikkaisivat sieltä, omista, palkoistaansa,
ettei ottaisii köyhyltä, eläkeläisiltä ja lapsiperheiltä.
Ja kulukorvaus, eikö riitä, kattoo, että täytyy taksilla ajaa loman aikanakin.
Kiitoksia, kiitoksia, hyvällä rarjolle.
Se on kukkonen veikko huomenta, tuota, kiahtiku tuossa äskesella saatu tuotu nettiä,
että, joka saa toimeentulo tukea, ni jos hän poimii marjoja ja myy, ni toimeentulo,
se vaikuttaa toimeentulo tukeen, tuen määrään, tämä marjoista saatu tulo,
eihän tässä oo mitään järkiä, tuota, nuini, elikkä, miksi, miksi, miksi, tuota, nuini.
Täsä maassa ois esimerkiksi sovoitumiseläkkeit ja kaikki teidän kansanelusten ylimääräiset, tuota, nuini.
Sieltä oo varaa ottaa.
Kertaa kaikkea, älä käydyt kehatko puuttua, tuota, pienitulosten ihmisten tulloihin,
ei se varmaise leipä ole liian leviää, tuota, nu, vielä kehataan tämmösen.
Tämä on törkeää, törkeää, törkeää, mutta, sitten jopa, joka kerää pulloja, omia pulloja, ni sitä pitää ruveta maksamaan veroa.
Siis, tämähän on sairasta. Eihän tuommoisia kahtasattaa pässiä tullaan tarvitaa tuolla Arkanianmäellä,
jotka puuttukaa oikeisiin asioihin, äläkäkä tämmösiin naurettaviin lillukan varsiin.
Tämä on törkeää, ei muuta. Kiitos, hei.
Noo, tässä on tämmönen työtön.
Aa, sitä meinaisit, ku aina puhutait työttämät marjamestääni.
Mä olen täällä marjassa käynyt nyt, ja aika köyhä mä edelleen, oo kyllä.
Ku puhutaist, meijan pitäis mennää metsää ja kerätä mar.
Kiitos, hei.
Kauniin kortin on meille lähettänyt tänne kansanradioon nimettömäksi jättäytyvä henkilö.
Kissassa on piirretty kuva viidestä kissasta, jotka nukkuvat, päällekkäin.
Muille olisi tuollainen hankalaa, mutta kissassa on kyllä lahjakas kaveri torkkumaan,
ihan kaikkialla ja missä vaan, ja koko ajan.
Tässä kortissa lukee, että neuvotaan, miten suojautua nettihuijareilta,
mutta eipä ole varmaa keinoa, tapaa, ettei joutuisi netissä rikollisten huijaamaksi.
Se on vähän kuin venäläistä rulettia, kun tekoälykin tuli rikollisille avuksi.
Mutta on yksi tapa, paras ja tehokkain, se on se, kun lopettaa digiasioinnin,
stressi laskee ja nukkuu paremmin.
Aika ennen digitalisaatiota oli sivistyneempi, inhimillisempi, fiksumpi ja järkevämpi, ja turvallisempi.
Nää lukee tänne saapuneessa kortissa, ohjelman lähes lopussa tulee sitten ne meidän yhteystiedot.
Ja seuraavaksi urheilua.
Kansaradio.
No ku, porillaisten marssia odotetaan.
Koska Vainio voitti Euroopan mestaruudelle.
Kyllä, Euroopan mestaruudelle, ilman muuta.
Nii just, jännitit koko kisan ajan.
No ihan koko kisan.
Tosin meni heti niin selvästi johtoon, että eihän sinä melkei edes tarvinnu jännittää, ku.
No, sitä hienompi, sitä hienompi voitto.
Ehdottomasti.
Aivan loistava suoritus.
Kyllä.
Paljon onnea hänelle, ja on porilaisten marssin paikka.
Oisko se porilaisten marssi aina, ku Suomelle tulee mitallia?
Vanhat perinteen kunia.
Hei, minä kiitän paljon, ku soitit.
Kiitos, kiitos, hyvää päivänjatko.
Kiitos, samoin, kiitos.
Eh, ei.
Moi.
Hei, mahtavaa.
Naiset pelastaa.
Jälleen kerran.
Kisat.
Moi.
No, yks akka täältä Espoosta vaan.
Hei.
Ollaanko me nyt noin miesten armoilla, että ei edes puolta tuntia kansan radiolle keskellä päivää löydy aikaa?
On pelkkää urheilu, ei me kaikki välitetä urheilusta.
Kiitos paljon tähän astisesta.
Se on ollut erittäin mielyttävää kuunnella aina kansanradiota.
Hei, hei.
Kansan radio.
No, täällä ois teemunutinen tuusillossa hyvää päivää.
Tuli mieleen täällä, et voi kuuntelut uskautta, katselin telkkaristakin vähän osittain.
Hieno, hiemiti hieno maratooni, oli se aine onnea vaan oli se aine onnea.
Va oli se aine onnea, vaan oli se aine koosii.
Suorittele, Lasse, tyttömä, maame laulu.
Oi, maame Suomi, synny maa, soi sana kultainen.
Ei laaksoa, ei kukkulaa, ei vettä ranta rakkaampaa.
Koi kotima, tää pohjoinen, maa kallis isien.
Hövä Suomi!
Minä kiitän paljon, ku soitit tänne ja lauloit maame laulu.
Ollaanko me tyytyväisiä Suomen mitalisaldo näistä kisoista?
Minä oon aine kiitän, mä oon aine, mä oon aine, mä oon aine, mä oon aine, mä oon aine, hyvä.
Kaks kulta, yks hopee.
Nii just.
Hei, tiedätkö, minä kiitän todella isosti, ku soitit ja lauloit maame laulu.
Päivä jatkottee.
Tämä, kui myös.
Jes, moi.
Aloi.
On monemmoista kysymystä soittajilla, joita kuullaan seuraavaksi, kunhan ensin luen tämän kikkakitkien lähettämän sähköpostin.
Hänkin siinä esittää kysymyksen, heti otsikossa, miksi ihmiset hankkivat omakotitalon.
Olen omakotitalo asukas ollut jo yli viisikymmentä vuotta.
Talomme on Turun kaupungin keskustasta noine neljä kilometriä, omakotitalo Kujan varrella.
Ihmetykseni on, miksi ihmiset hankkivat omakotitalon, jos eivät hoida oman talonsa kuntoa, ulkoverhoilua, kattoa, portin pieluksia, puutarhaa ja niin edespäin.
Koko Kujan häpeä pilkkuja ovat talot, jotka eivät ajattele naapureitaan sen verran, että oman tontin, kuusen ja koivun oksat eivät rehottaisi naapurin puolelle varjostaen naapurin pensasaitoja.
Miksi siis välinpitämättömät ihmiset hankkivat omakotitalon, jos rahkeet ja huolenpito eivät riitä siitä ja sen ympäristöstä huolehtimaan.
Kujallamme on myös postilaatikkoryhmiä.
Ja yhteen laatikkoryhmään on törmännyt auto, jonka seurauksena koko laatikkoryhmä on maanut maassa jo pari kuukautta.
Tulee syksyn sateet, talvelumet ja lumiaurat, taitaa laatikot mennä lumikasavallien alle.
Eli toinen kujan häpeä pilkku, eikä kukaan tee asialle mitää.
Nyt on minulla mitta täyssyy, siksi tämän kansan radioon vuodattelin terveisin kikkakitkiä.
Lahdesta yhdeksänkympinen mummo terve.
TV:ssä mainostetaan, koti ovelle tuodaan ruokaa sokos.
Olen soittanut, 150 metriä on sokoksen, ja Prismaan on 150.
Sokos sanoo, ei heille oo mitään palvelua, soittakaa Prismaan.
Ja siellä ei oo myöskään mitään palvelua, ei kotiin tuoda.
Haluaisin tietysti vain tämmösiä perusruokkeja, kuten maitoa, leipää, perunaa, porkkanaa ja niin edespäin.
Itse pystyn laitamaan, mutta kantamaan en voi, koska ne on painavia, nuo ruuvat.
Ja taksillä ei voi mennä, koska on nii lähellä, että taksi ei annistu, kyyti.
Mitä vartesokos mainostaa, vai onko se pelkästään sitten viina alkoholi, jota tuodaan kotiovelle?
Mutta mummo tei saa.
Miten saadaan, että kotin sais perusruokia tilattua, ette vois itse laittaa? Kiitos.
Ärsyttää tavattomasti, radion naiset.
Kun te aina hoitte, asia on niinku niinku. Selitäkääpä, mitä se niinku sisältää?
Miksi puhutte päälle, kuin rokkapata? Naurun kiherrystä selostellessa, vaikka se ei kuulu koko asian luonteeseen. Heippa.
Tiellä semmoinen oppimaton savolaispappalainen on vähän ihmeissään, tämä nykyisen puheetyylin kanssa, kun on tämmönen niinkus juttu tullut, nyt hyvin isosti muotiin, tuossa erilaisissa vierotusvälineissä ja telekarissa ja ratiossa.
Minusta se on nii mahtava, ku siellä tuommoiset oppineet ja muut toimittajat, nii ne ossoitu, nii kun sanoo käteen, nii mojovasti, että sinne ihan kuulostaa, että ne on pätevöityny, mollei muuhuni, kun ne osso sen nii pätevästi tuua esille.
Kun piäsis tuommoiselle kurssille tuota jossa, kun tietäs, missä niitä kurssia piirtän. Minustaki saattais tulla yhtä pätevä siinä hommassa, mut ku ei oo piäs. Minun vaan pitää kuunnella, ku muut on päteviä, enkä minä oo tuommoisen varmaan arpeiks viksu.
Ei tässä muuta, kiitoksia, moi.
No, Merja, tässä morjesta. Tässä jäin ihmettelemään semmoista juttua, ku tästän TV:tä katteleen, että miten se nettikiusaaminen loppuu sillä, että sä lahjotat rahaa jollekin tilille.
Ei mulla muuta, moi.
Mitä kuuluu?
Mulle ihmiset tää tämmönen homma, ku aikoinaan keksittyy tää diiselveroa.
Näille diiselautoille siitä, ku niil oo nii hirmo halpa se polttoaine.
Ja tänä päivänä se oo kalliimpaa, ku mikään pensa.
Ja diiselvero hyllää edelleenki.
Tässäkin miu ystävällä on 800 euroa, maksaa kuukaus, ajaa vajaa 2000 kilometriä vuodesta.
Se on se ihan järkyttävä homma, et se diiselvero oo mitenkään muutettu, sitä, ja kuka kansan edustelta on minkäännäköstä kantaa to hommat?
Eli kysymys kuuluu, että miksi tämä on vielä voimassa?
Niin, nime on.
Aa, se ihan kauhiaa, ku miettii tota hommat, ku se aluperi keksittii sen takke, ku diiseli oo nii hirmo halpaa.
Pensa maksoi silloo melkei kaks kertaa enemmä, ku diiseli siinä vaiheessa, mut tänä päivänä se oo toisiperi.
No, toisiperi, mut kuitenkii enemmä se diiseli maksaa, tänä ku kalliinkaan pensa.
Eikö löydy tuolta eduskunnasta tai sinne pyrkivistä ihmistä, joka olis ottanut tän asiakse?
No, sitä tässä ihmetellää, jostko ei, ei, tää kiinnostu tuo asia nii paljo.
Minkähän takia se, todellakaan oo agendalla, millää tavara tuos hommat?
Ku tuota varmaa, aika monta kiinnostuu, varsinkin jos ajiaa 2000 km vuoteen,
ja 800 euroa maksaa sitä diiseli veroa, siis sitä, mitä pensa ihminen ei maksa.
Johan, joku tolkku siinä pitäis olla, kyllä.
Joo.
Niikos.
Ni se vero perustuu anoperi siihen silloin, kun diiseli oli nii halpa,
että mitä pannai erilne veroa näille diiselkuskeille sitten.
No, et ei, tässä sen kummempaa, mut ihmetellä pitää.
Ja pitää esittää kysymyksiä, kun niitä on esitettävänä, ehdottomasti.
Hei, hyvää ku soitit. Kiitos.
No, kiitos, joo.
Moi.
Kylä me tähän loppuun kerätään vielä kuuntelemaan muutamia ehdotuksia, kehotuksia ja käskyjä.
Minä puolestaan en käske, vaan ehdotan ja kehotan, että se aihe, joka mielestäsi kaipaa enemmän huomiota,
oli se sitten ruusumaista tai risumaista, niin ota yhteyttä, kerro se meidän kautta, ihan kaikille.
Whatsappin välityksellä viestit numeroon 044, 55, 154, 64.
Sähköposti, kansan.radio, at yle.fi.
Kirjeposti, osoitteeseen, kansanradio, PL, 79, 000, 24, yleisradio.
Ja vastaajan numero vielä, se on 08, 00, 154, 64.
Ja ihmisvastaa ja se odottaa, kuten aina.
Kauluspaita päällä ja Mirri kaulassa, kello 12:30 ja 15:30 välillä, sunnuntaisin.
Lasse Olkinuora toivottaa oikein hyvää kesänloppumetrejä.
Kaikkien asioiden loppuminenhan ei ole hirveän mukavaa, mutta kesänloppumisessa on yksi sellainen hyvä puoli,
että sieltä se saapuu sitten seuraavaksi se syks.
Saa kumpparit jalassa ihminen ihastella ruskaa.
Ei muuta ku päiväjatkot.
Kansanradio.
Ja, haverin pettisäältä, ranuan eräämästä päivää.
Päivää.
Kuulkaako tuota, mulla on sellainen ajatus tullut tuota, kuuluuko sinne hyvin?
Kuuluu todella hyvin.
Joo, oikein hyvä.
Ku tääl on justkus katvealueita, ei taho saada millää yhteyksiä.
Joo, joo, kyllä kuuluu erittäin hyvin.
No, oikein hyvä.
Vii, tuota, mulla on tullut sellainen ajatus, että ikäihmiset on niinku tavallaan syrjäistetty tästä digimaailmasta.
Ja pankkipalvelujakin saa halua kerran viikossa, kolme tuntia, täältä Rovanina ki esinelee.
Aha.
Ni se on liian vähän.
Ja eräpäiväti pakkaa päälee, ja niitä pitää aina vähän muutella.
Ni, tuota, minä, on tullut ajatus, että minä ehdottasin näin, että jos joku kansa edustää tätä kautta alkaa soitamaan asiaa niin, että nuo kaikki kirjastot täällä,
nii, tuota, velvoitettaisiin auttamaan ikäihmisiä laskujen maksuissa.
Kirjastossa, kirjastoihin semmoinen palvelu, okei.
Ni, semmoinen palvelu kirjastoi, että se on niinku leikisesti sanottuna, se ois niinku toinen pankki.
Ni, joo, joo.
Ni, että siellä autettais ikäihmisiä, näin laskujen maksuissa, ja, ja, ja, sitten tuota, jos ne rahannostoja, semmoisia ole, mutta kuitenkin, että maksuja vois hoitaa.
Kää hakevassa jonkun Agatta Kristi.
No nii.
Ni, se ois oikein hyvä, jos tuota kirjastot saatais tuota auttaa maa ikäihmisiä laskujen maksuissa, että pysyisivät hänki asiat jollakin lailla ajantasalla.
No nii, sellaista ehdotusta minä kiitän siitä.
Tällainen ehdotus minul on tullu mieleen, kun kirjastoja käyttävät, vanhat ihmisetki käyttävät paljon kirjastoja, ja käyvät siellä, niin samalla voisivat saada laskujenki makset.
Minä kiitän paljon, kun soitit tämä juttu.
Oikei, oikei, hyvä, kiitoksia vielä.
Kiitos.
Kuulin.
Nolrasi, täältä Helsingia Alppiharjusta.
Kuulin Radio Suomesta, että sä nyt pohdität alinopeudesta sakottaa.
Nä, ihmette, miten riivatussa siitä voida sakottaa, jos ihminen ajaa alinopeutta?
Sehan osoittaa sitä, että ihminen ei kertakaikkiaan halua ajaa ylinopeutta, ku kaikesta pitäis vaan sakottaa, sakottaa, sakottaa.
Tämmönen paskavaltio tämä Suomen valtio on, että aina vaan sakotetaan, sakotetaan, sen sijaan, että ymmärtää niitä, jotka haluavat ajaa normaalia nopeutta.
Se normaalia nopeus tarkoittaa sitä, että sitä ajetaan tilanteen mukaan.
Tärki hoi, älä jätä, morjens.
Villisikaa asiaan, tähän semmoista ratkaisu, että, kun näitä villisikoja annattelema enemmin ja lisääntyy, niin, niitähän voisi antaa karhuille ja susille syötäväksi, nehän tykkää niistä kovasti.
Ei, muuta, kun karhuille, susille syötävä, koska ne tarvitteis sitä, niin, ne ei sitten söis niin paljon ihmisten, ihmisten, tuota, nii, lampaita, eikä.
Multa tuhoja tekis niin paljon, että ne, kun villisikoja siellä ampuvat ja niitä vähentävät, niin se ois parais ratkaisu, ei, muuta, kun karhuille ja susille syötävä, niin siellä ois oikea paikka sitten niille.
Tuoma täällä, päivä, semmoinen juttu, että Suomessa on paljon hyvää, ja yks niistä on, toi, meidän presidentti, että se on kyllä viimeisen päällä hieno mies, ja, maailman mies, ja, mä vähän, hä epäile, että, hä epäile, aina sappii, että, ku hän oli löytäny ne Kekkosen viinot, että, ettei vaan olis menny sieltä ottaa.
Etukätte, että, käyttäis nii varovasti niitä, että, Kekkonen osas käyttää niitä varovasti, että, pärjäis varman johtajien kanssa, että, voihan se tää, nykyinenkin residentti ottaa pienet neuvonantajat sieltä, että, jos tekee tiukkaa, että, kaikkee hyvää hänelle, kiitos, Varo.